child-oriented advertising
carries very strongly into the everyday life of children every day
1 bit into the nursery
and while we know
that children are particularly receptive to this advertising
are it is at the moment so
that 92 percent of these advertisements sell children on the internet
perceive on tv
for sweets
snacks and fast food for unhealthy food is
we must prevent
that the long-term influence has on the children
and there welandwirtschaftsminister Germany to me
create clear rules
and has submitted a proposal for this today
we reach into the arms of parents with these rules
because in many places
parents cannot protect their children alone
and need our support